guys like damn that girl looks good in
that dress and then she turns around she
doesn't kick and it's like oh [ __ ] she's
wearing shorts
wait a minute it's a one-piece that's a
romper I don't really know anything
about rompers my sense is that they're
like kind of the same thing as like
either jumpsuits or like onesies it's a
one-shot deal I think girls wear rompers
to brunch like all the mimosa brunches
they go to either better I feel like
it's like a nice summer things just a
very like simple way to make a strong
statement with one piece of clothing I'm
so nervous right now do I have to take
my clothes off I don't like might I have
a big torso I don't know where I start
putting my like I guess I put my legs in
first one up to have there's no zipper I
don't know which way is the prize
well really tight right there wait is
this right he's really right up this is
pretty easy actually I think we can
maybe get this to work nice and then I
just keep pulling up okay okay I got
this
there's pockets business just like I
think I have it on now I feel like I'm a
Couture gymnast the elastic makes me
feel like I can jump really high ha ha I
feel like I'm a member of ABBA I don't
know I think this actually like looks
pretty good
I wish the material is thicker and maybe
made of leather that would make me feel
like Beyonce right now I feel like
Taylor Swift trying to be Beyonce wow I
wonder if I would be able to oh I think
I could get it down the leg just you can
like just like go like that guys have
that option girls down we're a female
and I had to go really bad that could
people I'd be like it is in the bathroom
I thought take all this off you
literally just have to pull it all the
way down and you know sometimes their
urine on the floor I think the romper
would be ruined I do feel fancy like
this is nice like this is a nice color
there are ruffles up here I do like the
versatility I like how easy it is to put
on but I do feel like the like peeing
issue is a big one and it definitely
like a butt flat front flap I think
girls are awesome doing rubbers I think
that rompers are like the pinnacle of
efficiency for women women should wear
what they feel you know if this like
feels right on your body you know if
this feels right like I mean if you like
want to go dancing you don't know like I
don't know I don't know if this is like
dance I mean I don't know what kind of
dancing you do you could do a little bit
I don't know like whatever you feel like
lady is sweet you feel all been there is
a McNair like if you liked it then you
should've put a ring on it
oh geez now there's a big wedgie